die hitzewelle weitet sich zu einer
schlimmen dürre aus die nicht nur die
landwirtschaft betrifft auch die bäume
leiden sehr unter den hohen temperaturen
und vor allem in der stadt kämpfen sie
ums überleben und wir alle zusammen
können etwas tun klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen die tabelle
wird immer dramatischer nicht nur das
wer ernteausfälle von bis zu 70 prozent
haben sondern jetzt geht es auch den
bäumen an den kragen die ersten blätter
färben sich gelb die bäume bekommen
nicht mehr genug wasser und reagieren
problem vor allem in der stadt leiden
gerade die jungen bäume extremen die
kleinen baumscheiben um die bäume lassen
selbst wenn es regnet kaum wasser zu den
wurzeln und vor allem die jungen bäume
haben dann zu wenige wurzeln die tief
genug reichen um aus tieferen regionen
wasser nach oben zu pumpen hinzu kommt
dass ihre pumpleistung immer weiter
zurückgeht das haben forscher des max
planck instituts für biogeochemie jetzt
herausgefunden irgendwann ist der druck
sogar so niedrig dass das wasser
gasförmig wird und so den
wassertransport hemd wenn das in mehr
als 60 prozent der wasseradern im baum
passiert stirbt er ab damit ist zum
ersten mal klar wann bäume sterben
besonders davon betroffen sind eben die
jungen bäume und die vor allem in der
stadt sich sterben besonders schnell
während der hitzewelle hier in der
straße gibt es einen solchen baum er hat
es nicht überlebt aber wir können etwas
dagegen tun letztlich wurde ich gefragt
ob ich nicht mal ein video machen könnte
was wir gegen den klimawandel tun können
und deshalb schlug mehr johannes jojo
auf instagram vor zum gießen der bäume
aufzurufen also wir können etwas tun
wir können die bäume retten baum
experten und expertinnen empfehlen jetzt
die bäume zu wissen
dann können sie den heißen sommer
überleben deshalb macht alle mit bei
unserer aktion rettet die bäume schaut
bei euch in der umgebung nach jungen
beugen die vielleicht sogar schon
blätter abwerfen und liest sie
ordentlich mindestens sechs alba also 10
liste einmal wasser brauchen sie pro tag
macht videos postet und twittert und
nominiert andere youtuber und influenza
und motiviert jeden den wir kriegen
können dann können wir ein größeres
großes bäumen sterben in diesem jahr
verhindern das ist ganz einfach und wir
können etwas verändern und damit ihr
auch direkt zur tat schreitet gibt es
jetzt keine and card sondern nur eins
rettet die bäume und ich nominiere
open mind und simon will social media
new york bis dann bleibt dran